this video is sponsored by skillshare
kevin
hey hey the diamond shop scenes and
uncut gems are some of the most frantic
and chaotic scenes i think i've ever
seen in a film in the midst of this
chaos there is an
interesting creative choice that you
probably didn't notice
the safdies create a visual distinction
between the front of the diamond shop
and the back room by using two different
types of camera movement when shooting
out front they have the camera on a
steadicam
and when shooting in back they use
handheld camera movement
they use both in a similar way to
generate a chaotic energy but this very
intentional choice gives the two spaces
a distinct feel
that you almost certainly picked up on
despite not noticing the choice directly
the division illustrates how one space
is a place where howard has to perform
and be smooth
and another is a space where he can be
more vulnerable and unstable
with uncut gems the safety brothers are
pulling off a kind of sleight of hand
the film feels like it's out of control
and like it might fly off the rails at
any moment
but within that they're making careful
delicate choices that construct
a very specific experience let's get
underneath all the chaos and look at the
editing cinematography and sound to
examine how the safety brothers are so
carefully constructing such
an unhinged film
sound is the unsung hero of film
i'm almost there and i think it's one of
the most important components of the
tense atmosphere that uncut gems creates
the safety's ratchet up the tension of
the film by filling the soundscape with
sounds that are typically anxiety
producing in our own lives
come on all these things vie for our
attention audibly throughout the film
and it never allows us to truly relax
probably one of the most talked about
and noticeable uses of sound design in
the film
are the layers of dialogue that the
safeties use in many scenes in addition
to the primary dialogue that drives the
story
there are many overlapping pieces of
smaller dialogue that add texture
chaos and atmosphere to these scenes so
let me clean this first
let me throw them in the ultrasonic for
free okay
for free i would think you would have
bigger rocks than that just because
you're a big guy
okay see what y'all got in here who
would win in a fight ben wallace or tony
avenue
all day the safety's are very careful
with their mix while there are many
layers
and often background characters lines
will overlap with the primary dialogue
it's designed and mixed carefully enough
that you don't ever miss any important
information
in the most chaotic scenes characters
often repeat themselves
so if you miss a line the first time
you'll probably catch it the second time
the safti's captured a lot of
overlapping dialogue in the performances
but working together with sound designer
skip leave say
they also layered in a lot of additional
dialogue to make things even more
chaotic while additional dialogue
recording or adr
is usually used to re-record lines that
weren't clear enough in the original
recording or
to change small details in the plot the
safties wrote an additional 45-page
script of extra lines to record
to use as background filler for scenes
this technique
is impressive and very effective but
there's more to what's going on in the
sound design
the film's score is a unique evocative
and powerful force in the film
but what's most impressive is the way
the score
intertwines with the film's soundscape
watch this moment
and listen to how the timing of the car
horns fit perfectly with the rhythm of
the score
and the dialogue together eddie boy what
are you doing
what do you want look what i got look
you're going to love this
here hey what's that right there can you
leave me alone
here's another example listen to this
moment which you might need headphones
to hear as howard
unpacks the gem and begins to look at it
the score comes in
and the sound design becomes more
subjective and ethereal representing the
feelings evoked and howard by the gem
and for just a brief second the bubbling
of the fish tank in the background comes
into the mix howard hello
i'm standing here man there's a lot of
people i could be doing business with
other than you howard
it has this weird underwater texture for
a moment
and helps transition us into this
bizarre
soundscape almost created by the gem
it's a little genius touch of sound
design
that you'd almost certainly never notice
unless you were listening specifically
for the fully when i've criticized films
with bad editing in the past something
that has repeatedly come
up is a pace that is too fast but while
fast cutting can cause a lot of issues
it isn't inherently a problem
on its own uncut gems has a lot of great
examples
of how to do fast editing well let's
break down the auction scene twenty
thousand
thirty thousand do i have forty thousand
forty thousand gentlemen spit
pleasure to see you sir the scene is
just over three minutes long in the 187
seconds of this scene there are 90 cuts
that's an average of about two seconds
per shot so what makes the fast editing
in a scene like this
a disaster while in this one it works
great
and even benefits the scene the first
reason we'll look at is
rhythm while there's no music the
auctioneer's voice and delivery has a
distinct
cadence watch this small section and pay
attention how the timing of the cuts and
the natural rhythm of the auctioneer's
delivery work together
fifty thousand on a new place thank you
sir pleasure to have you back too sir
fifty thousand now against you sir
should we say sixty sixty thousand now
against you sir seventy thousand now
against you sir
one hundred grand 100 000 now for this
section
there's an established pace to the cut
50 000 on a new place thank you sir
pleasure to have you back too sir
50 000 now against you sir as soon as
kevin garnett cuts in with his
unexpectedly high bid it disrupts the
established rhythm of the edit for a few
beats
100 grand 100 000 now
then a new character the sort of villain
of the film enters the scene
and a longer shot places special
attention
on their entrance bid with you sir in a
great place a big bold giant leap
for a big bold giant leaper did you also
notice how the timing of the line's big
bold giant leap and big bold giant
leaper are matched with the entrance of
the two
characters rhythm isn't the only thing
that makes these quick
cuts work though each cut also has a
clear motivation or
intention one of the easiest ways to
motivate a shot is with an
eye line as humans we have an extremely
developed sense
of where people are looking and
naturally we pay close attention
to where the characters are looking on
screen
editors can use eye lines and the
movement of eyes to help direct our
attention
around a scene and to help things feel
cohesive let's look at this sequence of
shots that use
an unbroken series of eye lines first we
start with howard's father-in-law then
he glances at howard and we cut to
howard who is glancing back then he
glances towards the auctioneer and
that's where we cut the auctioneer
is looking at the father-in-law so we
cut there then we cut to
arno the father-in-law's eyeline wasn't
directed at arno but arno is looking at
the father-in-law so there's still a
meaningful connection between the two
shots it's subtle
but arno's eye line then shifts from the
father-in-law to howard and then we see
this over-the-shoulder pov
of arno looking at howard not every shot
is or needs to be connected via an eye
line like this
but using eye lines in this way links
one shot to the next
which keeps us from being confused about
why a cut was made
it's immediately obvious we're now
seeing what a character was looking at
having a super obvious motivation
is what helps keep us from becoming
confused or disoriented even as
the camera quickly shifts around the
room and between
many characters the eye lines in this
scene are also incredibly important
because they carry
much of the scene's conflict and drama
going into this scene
a complicated set of stakes and contexts
have been
established the safeties can play off
the underlying drama
to create conflict simply by having the
characters exchanging
looks howard's look of relief when
another bidder enters the fray
his father-in-law's look of doubt kg's
look of desire for the diamond
r knows confusion about what's happening
and then his disbelief as he
puts the pieces together all of this
emotional conflict and action is created
by the kuleshov effect we see a
character looking at something
and then it cuts to what they're looking
at and we infer a dramatic relationship
between the two
there are many great examples of good
editing throughout the film
but the speed of cutting in this scene
in particular is important because the
fast pace helps maintain
the tension and anxiety of the rest of
the film during a scene where the
characters are just
sitting and listening to what's
happening
the types of camera movement and the
focal lengths chosen by the safdie
brothers alongside cinematographer
darius kanji
played a big role in helping give many
of the scenes
chaotic momentum in the scenes in the
jewelry shop some of the most chaotic
and stressful in the film the brothers
primarily used a steadicam to give
themselves freedom
to move the camera around as much as
they wanted adding to the energy of the
scene but they did something
that really pushed this approach in a
unique direction by using more telephoto
lenses on a steadicam than what's normal
they were able to create an effect where
the movement through the space
feels exaggerated when howard walks
across the room and the camera follows
him or pants with him
the background moves past faster than it
would seem to with a wider lens
using this technique allows the camera
to move freely on many axes
at once it can swoop forward and
backward or move horizontally in one
direction
even as the lens is panning with a
character walking in another direction
for a shot like this one there are many
ways you could have set up a shot of
howard running down a hallway you could
stick the camera on a dolly and smoothly
track backwards as he runs
you could have the camera on a steadicam
with a wider lens and smoothly and
quickly drift straight backwards
you could have handheld camera and
frantically shakily follow him down the
hall
but instead the safties employ what
looks like
this steadicam telephoto lens
combination
which eliminates the shake and jitter of
a handheld shot but which still
swings from side to side almost
careening down the hall
the same way howard himself does less
stable than a dolly move
and more stable than a handheld camera
move this combination
of chaotic movement while still being
controlled i think embodies the ethos of
the safety's approach
i have every intention of paying you
back i'm broke right now use of more
telephoto lenses means the camera is
also further away from the characters
than it would have been if the wider
lens was used this means it's easier to
have characters
walk between the subject and the camera
creating layers of
motion between us and what we're trying
to focus on and pay attention to
this is an effect that the safeties
employ freely
much in the same way they use layers of
non-essential background dialogue to
partially obscure bits of primary
dialogue
in many scenes the camera dives forward
backwards
sideways and people obscure the frame
there are few or no establishing shots
to ground the geography of the space
we're in but like i talked about in the
editing section
things like eye line rhythm and
composition motivation
are still very intentional and ground us
in the midst of all this
it's easy when looking at a scene like
this one for the collection of
compositions to feel chaotic and random
but there are still clear patterns and
divisions that are being used to signify
meaning i already mentioned the shift
between handheld camera in the back room
and steadicam in the front but watch how
the composition gets tighter and less
chaotic
in this moment as howard and damani get
into an argument that neither of them
want kg to hear there's high energy to
this whole scene
but shifts in composition like this
still help separate
a long chaotic scene into recognizable
pieces
the specific use of zooms and key
moments as opposed to just
pushing in closer with a steadicam is
also another great example of this
all these decisions are the kinds of
visual choices that help
communicate certain emotions or
emphasize moments
that any good director will utilize but
for the safeties these very intentional
moments
while they still achieve their desired
effect are less immediately noticeable
unless you're looking for them in the
midst of all the movement that exists
just to create visual energy and chaos
in the scene it's the careful balance
between these two things that keeps the
film
from spinning out of control yeah did i
not tell you that was going to happen
yeah i'm sorry so now in each of these
areas i've talked about the safeties
have
a bit of a get out of jail free card
because they're creating a film that is
supposed to generate anxiety and
discomfort in the viewer
they can freely employ techniques more
chaotically that
other filmmakers would probably avoid
because they don't want to make their
audiences uncomfortable
but there's a big difference between
creating a sense of discomfort or
chaos that feels like it's part of the
story and experience
and just confusing the viewer with a
barrage of images and sounds
that they have a hard time understanding
within the context of the story
the difference between these two lies in
how carefully all these things
even when they are uncomfortable and
chaotic are arranged
it takes a mastery of cinematography
editing and sound to be able to craft an
experience that makes you
feel like you might slip loose and lose
the threat at any moment while in
reality
you're being led by the hand further
into the grip of its suspense
i know many of you are watching my
channel because you're interested in
filmmaking
making video essays or doing some kind
of creative work and no matter where you
are in that process or what you're
interested in creating
continuing to learn is extremely
important
skillshare my sponsor for this video is
a great way to do that
i've used skillshare to learn about
filmmaking graphic design
and productivity say you want to learn
more about cinematography
you could check out ryan booth's class
diy cinematography make your video look
like a movie what i love about this
class is that
ryan focuses on techniques that utilize
the existing environment like
how to use a window as a light source so
you can learn how to
improve your cinematography without
really needing a ton of fancy equipment
or the ability to build a set
skillshare is an online community with
thousands of classes that will
teach you new skills and inspire you to
get out there and create whether you're
just starting out or looking to
deepen your abilities from cooking to
video editing
skillshare has options for everyone and
the first 1000 people
to click the link in my description
we'll get a one month free trial
to skillshare premium so you can start
exploring your creativity today
skillshare is built for learning it's
easy to stay focused because there are
no ads to distract you
and they're constantly adding new high
quality
premium classes so click the link in the
description
to get your one month free trial and
start learning now i'm a big fan of
skillshare thanks again to them for
sponsoring this video
thank you so much to my patrons i
recently crossed a hundred patrons and
to celebrate that
i'm making a video for my patrons about
my top 25
favorite films so if you want to see
that or listen to the podcast where i
talk about what i've been watching every
month
go to patreon.com thomasflight to sign
[Music]
up